So we decided to do a single blind study for our caffeine and reaction time
experiment. So in a single blind study, the researcher knows what group the
particpants are in. There's another way that we can reduce bias in a study. And
that's by doing double blind study. So in a double blind study, neither the
researcher nor the participants know what group they're in. This will further
reduce bias by controlling for experimenter expectancy effect. For example,
let's say instead looking at caffeine's effect or reaction time, we want to
look at the effects of kindness. Well, maybe I as a researcher believe that
caffeine does make people more friendly. Well, when I interact with the
subjects to rate their kindness, the belief I have may cause me to be more
friendly towards them. Which may in turn make the subjects more friendly to me,
so my inconsistent treatment between the two groups may result in an
unintentional bias. And that can affect the results of my study.